Please tell me that this is like a PG-13 like and then we lost because you're telling me all the names and I was like did we lose Trent? Did we lose someone and that's why we're being so specific and okay everyone's alive. Everyone's alive. welcome to adsp the podcast episode 39 recorded on july 28 2021 my name is connor and today with my co-host bryce we interview sean parent and he tells us the story of how apple suitum and steve jobs stepped in to save the day have we ever had sean tell the story about the time that Photoshop crashed during Chinese New Year and created like an international incident? And Sean got an offer from a U.S. senator or something. Have we had that story here? So, yeah, you're referring to what's known as the Basimatic story, which I'm going to put that one on the shelf because that one, you know, that's a story for drinks over the bar. There's still some people who are very sensitive to that story.
请告诉我这就像是PG-13级别的，然后我们刚才断片了，因为你一直在说所有的名字，我当时就想，我们是不是把特伦特（Trent）弄丢了？我们是不是把谁弄丢了，所以我们才说得这么具体？好吧，大家都在。大家都活得好好的。欢迎收看adsp播客第39期，于2021年7月28日录制。我是康纳（Connor），今天和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起采访肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent），他给我们讲述了苹果公司起诉他以及史蒂夫·乔布斯（Steve Jobs）出面解围的故事。我们以前听肖恩讲过那次Photoshop在农历新年期间崩溃并引发类似国际事件的故事吗？而且肖恩还收到了来自美国参议员之类的邀请。我们在这里听过那个故事吗？所以，是的，你指的是所谓的巴斯马蒂克（Basimatic）故事，我要把它先搁在一边，因为那个，你知道的，那是适合在酒吧喝酒时聊的故事。还有一些人对那个故事非常敏感。
Okay. So that tends to not go public um and if sean says it's too sensitive to be repeated then you can take it yeah yeah so so we'll leave leave that one hanging out there for your listeners um uh yeah so kind of you know in in conversations and on twitter, two stories came up. So I'll let you guys flip the coin and choose. One was the one that Tony mentioned, which he was kind of mentioning the punchline, which he said, you know, wasn't there. I forget how he phrased it, but wasn't there an individual after the whole Cyan proposal, which was the story we told before, who said that he had been asked at Apple to figure out why that couldn't work. And he saw my name at the top of the paper and said, oh, no, it'll work. So that's the punchline of the story.
好吧。所以这往往不会公开，而且如果肖恩说这太敏感了不能重复，那你就当没听过。好吧，好吧，所以我们就把这个故事留给你们的听众去想象了。嗯，好，所以在交谈中和推特上，出现了两个故事。所以我让你们抛硬币来选择。一个是托尼（Tony）提到的那个，他有点像是在说笑话的包袱，他说，你知道的，当时不在。我忘了他是怎么表达的，但不是在整个西恩（Cyan）提案（那是我们之前讲过的情节）之后，有个人说他在苹果被要求弄清楚为什么那个方案行不通？然后他看到纸的最上面有我的名字，就说，哦，不，这行得通。所以这就是故事的包袱。
But there's a good story for how we get there. The other story is how at one point Apple sued me, and it was Steve Jobs who actually saved me. I think we've got to hear how Steve Jobs saved Sean. Don't worry, listeners. we're not going anywhere. I mean, at least, uh, at one point I think I told Sean that he should have his own podcast and he said, I know I don't have time for that. I don't have the bandwidth. Uh, he said, however, if, if you had a podcast and you just want it to be a recurring guest, I'd be more than happy to do that. And I said, okay, done. Okay, so story time here.
但我们是怎么走到这一步的，这背后有一个精彩的故事。另一个故事是，苹果曾在某个时候起诉我，而实际上是史蒂夫·乔布斯救了我。我想我们一定得听听史蒂夫·乔布斯是怎么救肖恩的。别担心，听众朋友们。我们哪儿也不去。我的意思是，至少，嗯，有一次我想我告诉过肖恩他应该有自己的播客，他说，我知道，我没有时间做这个。我没有那个精力。嗯，他说，不过，如果你有一个播客，而且你只是想让我当常驻嘉宾，我非常乐意这么做。我说，好吧，一言为定。好吧，现在是讲故事时间。
So this goes way back, and it's a little kind of outside of tech, but, you know, ties into tech. I was in college, so the year is 1984. I had to look this up, and I believe it was 84. It kind of spans into 85 for the length of the story here. And I was working at a computer reseller called Microcomputer Systems. They were in Bellevue Square, for anybody who knows the Seattle area. So it's a mall, and, you know, selling computers at a mall. And they were an Apple dealer before Apple had their own stores.
所以这要追溯到很久以前，它有点游离于科技界之外，但是，你知道的，又和科技息息相关。我当时上大学，那是1984年。我特意查了一下，我相信是84年。故事的发展一直持续到了85年。我当时在一家名为“微型计算机系统”（Microcomputer Systems）的电脑经销商那里工作。他们位于贝尔维尤广场（Bellevue Square），了解西雅图地区的人应该都知道。所以那是一个购物中心，你知道的，就是在商场里卖电脑。在苹果拥有自己的专卖店之前，他们就是苹果的经销商。
And the Macintosh was newly out, and Apple ran a sales promotion for the Macintosh that was called I'd Rather Be Driving a Macintosh. And in fact, I still have a bumper sticker. You can probably find images of these bumper stickers online. So I've got a bumper sticker with the rainbow Apple logo that says I'd rather be driving a Macintosh. And the basic idea of the promotion is it was trying to get people in to test drive a Macintosh at an Apple dealer and so you could schedule a time to come into an Apple dealer, and they would kind of walk you through a canned demo
当时麦金塔（Macintosh）刚刚问世，苹果为麦金塔推出了一项名为“我宁愿驾驶麦金塔”（I'd Rather Be Driving a Macintosh）的促销活动。事实上，我到现在还有一个汽车保险杠贴纸。你可能还能在网上找到这些保险杠贴纸的图片。所以我就有一张印有彩虹苹果标志的贴纸，上面写着“我宁愿驾驶麦金塔”。这个促销活动的基本理念是，它试图吸引人们到苹果经销商那里去试驾麦金塔，你可以预约时间去苹果经销商那里，他们会带你体验一个预先录好的演示，
and try to convince you to buy a Mac. And part of the test drive is you could even take a Mac home for like a week and try it out and then bring it back. That's kind of a test drive. So part of the sales promotion was a SPF for the Apple salespeople, where for every 10 Macintoshes you sold, you got entered into a drawing to win a Porsche 944 for a year. It would be a one-year lease on this car. Wow, that's pretty cool.
并试图说服你购买Mac。作为试驾的一部分，你甚至可以把Mac带回家用一个星期左右，体验一下再还回来。这算是一种试驾。所以作为促销活动的一部分，针对苹果的销售人员有一个激励计划，你每卖出10台麦金塔电脑，就可以获得一次抽奖机会，有机会赢得一辆保时捷944一年的使用权。这将是这辆车的一年期租赁权。哇，这太酷了。
Pretty cool. And there was just, you know, across all the Apple dealers, you know, across the whole country, there was one Porsche 944 that was going to be given out in this drawing. And at our store, we pooled all of our max sales under our manager's name. Our manager was ron to maximize our number of chances to win this car and uh and ron won yeah so So we agreed, and Ron agreed, that what we would do is once we, you know, had the car with the year lease, is we would just divvy up the car across the salespeople. There were four of us, including Ron, based off how many Macs we'd actually sold. So we would, you know, take the year, divide it up by the number of Macs we sold,
非常酷。而且，你知道的，在所有的苹果经销商当中，在全国范围内，这次抽奖将送出一辆保时捷944。在我们的店里，我们将所有的Mac销量都挂在我们经理的名下。我们的经理叫罗恩（Ron），为了最大限度地增加我们赢得这辆车的机会，然后，罗恩中奖了。所以我们同意了，罗恩也同意了，等我们拿到这辆租期一年的车后，我们就把车在销售人员之间分摊。我们有四个人，包括罗恩在内，根据我们实际卖出的Mac数量来分。所以我们会，你知道的，用这一年除以我们卖出的Mac数量，
and you would get that percentage of time driving the would take the year, divide it up by the number of mechs we sold, and you would get that percentage of time driving the car during the year. And we thought that was fair. And so Ron flew down to Cupertino and met with Steve Jobs and got the car, got to drive the car back up from Cupertino back up to Washington. And we divvied up the car, you know, who got to use it between the people on the team. And I was taking the last section, and I think initially I had like two months for the car. But I ended up getting more time because as people got expensive tickets driving this car, they like handed it off to the next person. They were like, okay, that just cost me a bunch of money and my insurance rates are up.
你就能得到这一年中驾驶这辆车相应的时间比例。你会用这一年除以我们卖出的Mac数量，然后你就能得到这一年中驾驶这辆车相应的时间比例。我们觉得这很公平。于是罗恩飞到库比蒂诺（Cupertino），见到了史蒂夫·乔布斯，拿到了车，然后一路把车从库比蒂诺开回了华盛顿。我们把车分好，你知道的，在团队成员之间分配谁来使用它。我是安排在最后使用的，我想最初我大概有两个月的车的使用权。但我最终得到了更多的时间，因为当人们开着这辆车拿到昂贵的超速罚单时，他们就会把车转交给下一个人。他们会想，好吧，这刚刚让我花了一大笔钱，而且我的保险费也涨了。
You take it. And during that time, we also kind of traded off a bit, where it was like, oh, well, I don't need the car for this week, and I've got something to do this week, so could I use the Porsche? We're all college kids, for the most part, except for Ron. So I was the only person at this point who didn't have a ticket in the car, and I had three months ticket in the car, and I had three months to use the car, and I was down to the last two weeks on the lease.
你拿着它。在那期间，我们也做了一些调换，比如，哦，这周我不需要车，而这周我有点事要做，所以能让我用一下保时捷吗？我们基本上都是大学生，除了罗恩。所以当时我是唯一一个车里没有罚单的人，我用了这辆车三个月，租赁期只剩下最后两周了。
And I was living in downtown Seattle, and my now wife, Tricia, she was visiting her family down in Southern California, and I got invited to a party. So I called up a couple of friends of mine, Joe and Pat, and a cousin of mine, Trent, and said, hey, I got invited to this party. Do you guys want to go? Like, that would be great.
当时我住在西雅图市中心，我现在的妻子特里西亚（Tricia）当时正在南加州探亲，我受邀去参加一个派对。所以我打电话给我的几个朋友乔（Joe）和帕特（Pat），还有我的表弟特伦特（Trent），说，嘿，我受邀去参加一个派对。你们想去吗？那太好了。
I'm like, I've got the Porsche. We'll drive to this party and have a good time. So at the very last minute, Pat called and said, I can't go to the party. And he bails. And so it was just myself and Joe and Trent. And we're driving the Porsche to this party and there's a windy road out by Issaquah, Washington called Tiger Mountain, which is like a, you know, roller coaster. It's, you know, up and down and banked curves and kind
我说：“我有保时捷。我们将开着车去这个派对，度过一段美好的时光。”所以在最后一刻，帕特打电话说：“我不能去派对拉。”他放了鸽子。所以最后只有我和乔还有特伦特。我们开着保时捷去参加这个派对，华盛顿州伊萨夸（Issaquah）附近有一条蜿蜒的道路，叫做老虎山（Tiger Mountain），就像过山车一样。你知道的，它有上坡、下坡、倾斜的弯道，而且，
of notorious for being a fun drive. And so I kind of unleashed the car going up the hill and it was like, ah, that was fun. Let's do it again. So I turn around and start down the hill and coming over a knoll around a bend the car goes loose and starts to slide and the roadway here it's you know it's a fairly steep kind of mountainous area there's no guardrail and if i went off on the outside of the of the curve it was you know off a hill into big trees and and so all i can remember thinking is like keep the car to the inside of the curve like no matter what happens keep the car to the inside of the curve and and my memory was was hitting the gravel knowing that i was on the inside of the curve. And my memory was hitting the gravel, knowing that I was on the inside of the curve, the car just hitting the gravel, coming to a stop,
以惊险刺激的驾驶体验而闻名。所以当我上山时，我有点释放了这辆车的性能，心想：啊，这太好玩了。我们再来一次。所以我调头开始下山，在一个弯道的山岗上，车子突然失控开始打滑。这里的路面，你知道的，是一个相当陡峭的山区，没有护栏，如果我在弯道外侧冲出去，你知道的，就会冲下山坡撞进大树里。所以我脑子里唯一能想到的就是：无论如何要把车控制在弯道内侧——不管发生什么，都要把车控制在内侧。我记得自己压上了碎石路面，心里知道自己是在弯道内侧。我记得车子压过碎石，停了下来，
and me thinking, oh, whew, we're all fine, everything's okay. But my next memory is a firefighter yelling at me from outside the car to stay awake while they're prying the door off the car to get me out. What? Yeah. So I don't remember the impact, but we swapped ends and went backwards into a telephone pole at an estimated speed of about 70 miles an hour. What the heck? Yep. So the telephone pole ripped through the rear axle of the car.
当时我想：“哦，呼，我们都没事，一切都好。”但我的下一个记忆是一名消防员在车外对我说，让我保持清醒，同时他们正在用撬棍把车门撬开把我弄出来。什么？是的。所以我不记得撞击的瞬间了，但我们车身调头，以大约每小时70英里的估计速度倒着撞上了一根电线杆。搞什么鬼？是的。所以电线杆直接撞穿了汽车的后轴。
I have pictures of the negatives, at least I found them recently, of the car. So the telephone pole ripped through the rear axle. The car had a sunroof. The sunroof came off and it was, you know, I was driving. My cousin Trent was sitting in the front passenger seat. The telephone pole went through the rear. What? Yeah. passenger seat what yeah yeah you hit you hit the
我有这些底片的照片，至少我最近找到了它们，是关于这辆车的。所以电线杆撞穿了后轴。这辆车有天窗。天窗飞了出去，当时我在开车。我的表弟特伦特坐在副驾驶座上。电线杆从后面穿了过来。什么？对。副驾驶座。什么？对，对。你们撞上了——
telephone pole we going backwards backwards okay we swapped ends and went backwards into the telephone pole right so and nobody died and nobody died
电线杆。我们当时是在倒车吗？倒车。好吧，我们掉了个头，倒车撞上了电线杆，对吧？而且没有人死。而且没有人死。
um so I'm thinking in the back of my head I'm like Sean And nobody died? And nobody died. As I'm thinking in the back of my head, I'm like, Sean, please tell me that this is like a PG-13. And then we lost it because you're telling me all the names. And I was like, did we lose Trent? Did we lose someone? And that's why we're being so specific. And so, okay, everyone's alive. Everyone's alive.
嗯，我在脑子里想，我说，肖恩，请告诉我这就像是PG-13级别的。然后我们断片了，因为你一直在说所有的名字，我当时就想，我们是不是把特伦特弄丢了？我们是不是把谁弄丢了，所以我们才说得这么具体？好吧，大家都在。大家都活得好好的。
Yeah. So we'll walk through the injuries a little bit here. So the the sunroof popped and and and went back. The roof crumpled. The back seat got squished into the front seat. So the back Joe was sitting behind Trent. So he's on the on the on the right side of the if you're facing out the front windshield, he's on the right side of the car. And so his seat got pushed, like smashed up against the seat in front of him. And he would have been crushed except the sunroof popped, so he ended up pinned between the two seats, standing out the top of the car.
是的。所以我们简单回顾一下受伤情况。当时天窗弹开并飞了出去。车顶严重变形。后座被挤压进了前座。所以坐在后面的乔坐在特伦特的后面——如果面向前风挡的话，他在车的右侧。所以他的座位被向前推，紧紧贴在他前面的座位上。如果不是天窗弹开了，他本会被压扁的，结果他被夹在两个座位之间，上半身露在车顶外面。
And his only injury was a gash from kind of just before, just below his shoulder down to about his elbow, where his, as he got squished up, the roof crumpled down. And so it left a sharp edge and it just gouged down his arm. So that was his injury. Trent had a concussion because of all things. There was a radar detector clipped on the visor that came off and clipped him in the forehead and gave him a good concussion from that. This was before airbags, so I rebounded and bounced off the steering wheel. So I had a good concussion and I also chipped a bone in my shin. I'm not sure what I hit it on, but something under the front of the car and so so yeah so kind of my next memory after impact was coming to with the firefighters out
他唯一受的伤是一道划伤，从肩膀下方一直延伸到手肘附近，因为在车身受到挤压、车顶向下塌陷时，形成了一个尖锐的边缘，在他的手臂上划开了一道大口子。这就是他受的伤。特伦特得了脑震荡，因为不知怎么的，遮阳板上夹着一个雷达探测器掉了下来，正好砸在他的额头上，把他撞成严重脑震荡。当时还没有安全气囊，所以我向前弹起，撞到了方向盘上。因此我也得了严重的脑震荡，我的小腿骨也骨折了。我不确定我是撞到了什么上面，但肯定是车头下方的某个东西。所以，是的，在撞击之后，我的下一个记忆就是在消防员的帮助下清醒过来——
Trent had managed to get out of the car and and then had managed to help Joe out of the car so they were already out of the car I was unconscious in the car and pinned. And somebody nearby heard the squealing tires and it called the police. So the police had come and they'd called the fire department and the fire department had come. So I was unconscious for a while and fire department pried me out. So I have kind of these little flashes of memory from all of this, right? Like I said, I remember the car coming to a stop, not impacting anything. Then I remember the firefighters yelling at me. Then my next memory is being out of the car and asking Joan Trent if they were okay. And then I have a memory sitting in the back of the police squad car with a
特伦特设法爬出了车，然后又设法把乔拉出了车，所以他们当时已经脱困了。我则在车里昏迷不醒，被卡住了。附近有人听到了轮胎摩擦地面的尖叫声并报了警。于是警察赶到了，他们叫了消防队，消防队也赶到了。所以我昏迷了一段时间，是消防队把我撬出来的。所以关于这一切，我只有这些零星的记忆碎片，对吧？就像我说的，我记得车子停了下来，没有撞到任何东西。然后我记得消防员冲我大喊。再然后我的记忆就是已经出了车祸，正在问乔和特伦特他们有没有事。接着我记得自己坐在警车后座上，
police officer asking if I'm okay. And then I have a short memory of waking up in a hospital briefly and then a memory of being at my parents' house. And I don't know, like, who called my parents, but my parents had lived in the area. And so, yeah, I was kind of in and out of it for a while. So accidents over, cars totaled, we're all okay. At my parents' house, I called Tricia and let her know that, oh, you know, the party we were going to, we never even made it there, crashed the Porsche, it's totaled, and she asks, you know, what happened to Trent and Joe, and I fill her in on those details, and she goes, what about Pat? And the words out of my mouth were, oh, Pat didn't make it. And it took me a while because my wife just like went into hysterics
警察问我有没有事。然后我隐约记得在医院短暂醒来，接着就是在我父母家里的记忆。我不知道是谁给我父母打的电话，但我父母当时就住在附近。所以，是的，我有一段时间处于意识模糊的状态。所以事故结束了，车报废了，我们都平安无事。在我父母家里，我给特里西亚打了电话，告诉她：“哦，你知道我们要去的那个派对，我们根本没去成，保时捷撞毁了，报废了。”她问：“特伦特和乔怎么样了？”我把这些细节告诉了她，然后她问：“那帕特呢？”我脱口而出的话是：“哦，帕特没能去。”这让我费了一番口舌，因为我妻子在电话那头直接崩溃了，
on the other end of the phone, just like sobbing. And she like, you know, couldn't hear me. And it was like, well, I'm trying to say, no, no, no, no, no, I meant, like, he canceled. He didn't go to the party. He wasn't in the car. So, yes, she thought that I had killed our friend Pat. But luckily that was not the case. Pat had bailed. I also think had Pat actually been in the car,
泣不成声。她根本听不进去我说话。我当时极力想解释：“不，不，不，不，我是说，他取消了行程。他没去派对。他不在车里。”所以，是的，她以为我把我们的朋友帕特给害死了。但幸运的是，事实并非如此。帕特放了鸽子。我也觉得，如果帕特当时真的在车里，
I probably might not have totaled it because Pat was a very experienced race car driver, and he probably would have said, you're being an idiot here, so cut it out. So that all happens. There's, you know, medical bills and hospital bills and a total Porsche. And Apple's insurance company is a company called Industrial Indemnity. And I get a letter from Industrial Indemnity that says, hey, we were just looking things up and you're not on the lease for this car. You had no business driving it. So we're suing you for the car, the hospital bills, the legal fees, all of this. Which as a college student, this is a pretty daunting thing. I think even as an adult, this would be a very daunting
我可能就不会把车撞报废了，因为帕特是一个非常有经验的赛车手，他很可能会说：“你现在这样太蠢了，给我收敛点。”所以这一切就这么发生了。然后有医疗费、住院费，还有一辆报废的保时捷。苹果公司的保险公司是一家名为“工业赔偿”（Industrial Indemnity）的公司。我收到了一封来自工业赔偿公司的信，上面写着：“嘿，我们刚刚查了资料，你不在文件的承租人名单上。你根本不应该开这辆车。所以我们要就汽车、住院费、律师费等所有这些费用起诉你。”作为一个大学生，这是一件相当令人畏惧的事情。我想即使对一个成年人来说，这也是一件非常令人生畏的
thing. But Ron, my boss at Microcomputer Systems, wasn't an idiot. And when he had gone to pick up the car, there had been a little ceremony with Steve Jobs handing him the keys to the car, and he gets to meet Steve Jobs. And he asked Steve, he said, hey, Steve, I would like to use this car as incentive for my salespeople at the store. Would that be okay? And Steve said, yeah, that would be okay. And Ron said, would you mind, like, writing that down? And so Steve wrote, Ron can use the car. I wouldn't have let anybody drive the car without permission.
事情。但是罗恩，我在微型计算机公司的老板，可不傻。当他去提车时，曾有一个小小的仪式，史蒂夫·乔布斯亲手把车钥匙交给了他，他还得以见到了史蒂夫·乔布斯。他问史蒂夫：“嘿，史蒂夫，我想把这辆车作为我们店里销售人员的奖励。这样可以吗？”史蒂夫说：“可以，这没问题。”罗恩又说：“你介不介意把它写下来？”于是史蒂夫写道：“罗恩可以使用这辆车。如果没有得到允许，我是不会让任何人开这辆车的。”
I've got Steve Jobs' permission on this cocktail napkin. And so I go into a meeting with the insurance company and a bunch of lawyers, and I hadn't even hired my own lawyer at this point. So it's like just me on the other side of this table. And, you know, they're explaining to me basically how much money I'm going to owe. And I said, well, you know, I actually did have permission to drive the car. And I slide this napkin across the table. And they're like, you you know what's this and i'm like that's uh steve jobs ceo of apple who's gave me permission to
我手里拿着写有史蒂夫·乔布斯同意的鸡尾酒餐巾纸。于是我和保险公司以及一群律师开会，当时我甚至还没请自己的律师。所以桌对面就只有我一个人。而且，你知道的，他们基本上在向我解释我将欠多少钱。我说：“嗯，其实我确实得到了驾驶这辆车的许可。”我把这张餐巾纸推过桌子。他们说：“你知道，这是什么？”我说：“那是史蒂夫·乔布斯，苹果公司的CEO，他批准我
to drive this car and they're like yeah no right so so i'm like no that's that's what this is and so there's a bunch of like back and forth and conversation and eventually somebody says okay i'm gonna go make some phone calls and it took like an hour but somebody actually got a hold of steve thanks to steve i i ended up not getting sued i can't believe this story is like pre all of you're in college at this point i thought for sure this was like a college you know like so this so this is pre-everything, like pre-Adobe, pre-Google, pre-Apple. As a college student, you got sued by Steve Jobs. Or no, you got sued by Apple and Steve Jobs saved you. Yep.
开这辆车的。”他们说：“哦，得了吧，真的吗？”所以我说：“不，这就是真的。”经过一番来来回回的交涉和对话，最终有人说：“好吧，我去打几个电话。”大概花了一个小时，但通过史蒂夫，有人真的联系上了他。多亏了史蒂夫，我最终没有被起诉。我简直不敢相信这个故事竟然发生在你们上大学之前。我当时还以为这绝对是大学时期的事，你知道的——所以这一切都发生在一切之前，比如Adobe之前、谷歌之前、苹果之前。作为一名大学生，你居然被史蒂夫·乔布斯起诉了。或者说，不对，你是被苹果起诉了，然后史蒂夫·乔布斯救了你。是的。
So you were destined to go and have, you know, one-'re not one-on-ones but like that's amazing yep and you know sadly i never got to tell this story to steve jobs i have told the story to uh to steve wozniak so who got a good laugh what uh yeah so so steve wozniak came and uh to uh m MACAC one year. We talked about MACAC last time. So he came as a keynote speaker and hung out with everybody at MACAC for a long time. So I had the chance there to tell him the story. But yeah, never had a chance to tell Steve the story. Let him know that, yeah, I was the guy who totaled the Porsche.
所以你命中注定要去拥有，你知道的，不是一对一，而是那种——这太惊人了。是的，而且可悲的是，我从来没有机会把这个故事讲给史蒂夫·乔布斯听。我把这个故事讲给了史蒂夫·沃兹尼亚克（Steve Wozniak）听，他听了觉得很好笑。嗯，是的，所以史蒂夫·沃兹尼亚克有一年去了MacHack大会。我们上次聊过MacHack。所以他作为主题演讲嘉宾出席，并在MacHack和大家一起待了很长时间。所以我当时有机会把这个故事讲给他听。但是，是的，从来没有机会把这个故事讲给史蒂夫（乔布斯）听。让他知道，是的，我就是那个把保时捷撞报废的家伙。
Wow. Steve the story. Let him know that, yeah, I was the guy who totaled the Porsche. Oh, wow. Yeah, I got threatened to be sued one other time from Apple. And this was, I worked at a little company, Micro, or not Microcomputer Systems, Orange Micro. You know, graduated from college
哇。把这个故事讲给史蒂夫听。让他知道，是的，我就是那个把保时捷撞报废的家伙。哦，哇。是的，我曾受到过苹果公司的另一次起诉威胁。当时我在一家小公司工作，叫Micro（微型），或者说不是Microcomputer Systems，而是Orange Micro。你知道的，大学毕业后，
and I was, I think we talked about this some before, I was doing printer driver stuff. And I was reverse engineering Apple's printer drivers and was stuck on one, and I was communicating with Scott Boyd, who, he was also Blue Meanie, and he was somebody who I met at MacHack,
我当时在做打印机驱动程序相关的工作，我想我们之前已经聊过一些了。我在对苹果的打印机驱动程序进行逆向工程，有一个地方卡住了，于是我与斯科特·博伊德（Scott Boyd）进行了交流，他也是“蓝色恶魔”（Blue Meanie）成员，是我在MacHack认识的人，
and so we're still good friends to this day. But he was in tech support at Apple at the time, and I was communicating with him and asking him how some things worked on one of the image writer drivers. I don't remember if it was the LQ or the original image writer, but I said to Scott, I said, you know, instead of just telling me all this stuff, it would be super handy if you could just send me the sources.
所以我们至今仍是好朋友。但他当时在苹果的技术支持部门工作，我与他交流并询问关于其中一个图像书写器（ImageWriter）驱动程序的一些工作原理。我不记得是LQ还是最初的ImageWriter了，我对斯科特说，你知道的，与其告诉我所有这些，如果你能直接把源代码发给我，那就太方便了。
And he was like, oh, sure. So he sent me the sources to one of the drivers, which he should not have done. And so he then kind of realized afterwards that that probably wasn't the best thing to do. So he asked his manager, you know, is it okay that I send this guy the sources? He was like, oh, absolutely not.
他当时就说：“哦，没问题。”于是他把其中一个驱动程序的源代码发给了我，他不该这么做的。随后他意识到这可能不是最好的做法。于是他问他的经理：“我把源代码发给这个人，可以吗？”经理回答：“哦，绝对不行。”
And so I got this, you know, nasty gram from Apple, basically threatening to sue me if I didn't destroy all copies of the sources immediately and wipe them out, and I guess Scott almost got fired through this. So we laugh about this from time to time that i almost got him fired too with my uh but uh uh yeah you know i just complied with the letter and it was not a not a big issue wow i still can't get over i still can't get over the last we also should put some like disclaimer about uh if you ever win a Porsche or even if you don't win a Porsche and you have a vehicle
于是我收到了苹果公司发来的一封严厉的信，基本上威胁说如果我没有立即销毁所有源代码的副本并将其彻底清除，就要起诉我。我猜斯科特也因此差点被解雇。所以我们有时会拿这件事开玩笑，说我当时也差点因为我而害他被解雇。但是，嗯，是的，你知道的，我只是照信里说的做了，这并不是什么大问题。哇，我还是无法释怀，我还是无法释怀上一次。我们还应该加上一些免责声明，关于如果你赢得了一辆保时捷，或者即使你没有赢得保时捷，但你有一辆车，
and you look up to Sean, please do not attend to his behavior. Only look up to his C++ coding abilities, not to his irresponsible driving. The lesson is if you have a Porsche, don't let Sean drive the Porsche. Yeah, or any high-performance vehicle, for that matter. Yeah, and the stories of my youth, my cousin Trent and I were notorious. Almost every time we got together, it ended up in an emergency room visit from the time we were six on so so there are many stories of the two of us uh uh kind of egging the other one on until it ends up in an emergency room visit sean sean parent the you know the c++ luminary in his youth
而且你很崇拜肖恩，请千万不要模仿他的行为。只能学习他的C++编程能力，不要学他那不负责任的驾驶习惯。给我们的教训是：如果你有一辆保时捷，千万别让肖恩开保时捷。是的，或者任何高性能汽车，都是如此。是的，说到我年轻时的故事，我和表弟特伦特可是出了名的。从我们六岁开始，几乎每次我们聚在一起，都会以进急诊室告终。所以我们俩有很多故事，互相挑衅对方，直到最后不得不去急诊室。肖恩·帕伦特，那个C++领域的泰斗，在年轻时
just breaking bones constantly concussing himself yeah you know i was a you know kid in the in the in the 70s and it was kind of free range right it was uh we got up in the morning and on a weekend and left the house and went to play with our friends that lived in a rural area you know jumped off train trestles into the river and swam in a lake and the only rule was you had to be home when the streetlights came on. Where did you grow up? Halfway between Renton and Issaquah
却一直在骨折、脑震荡。是的，你知道的，我是70年代的孩子，那时的生活方式相当无拘无束，对吧？我们在周末的早晨起床，离开家，去找住在农村的朋友玩，从铁路桥上跳进河里，在湖里游泳。唯一的规矩就是路灯亮了之前必须回家。你在哪里长大的？在华盛顿州的伦顿（Renton）和伊萨夸（Issaquah）之间。
in Washington State. I still don't know how I'm just like, wow, how come I wasn't sued by some big company? And the reason I was being sued I mean ideally it's not because I totaled a Porsche but like because I won a Porsche and uh yeah there's just so many amazing just even the fact that you like sure you you had the statistics in your favor by pulling them but what are the odds that that actually works across the whole country, right? Yeah, yeah.
我还是不明白我当时怎么会想：“哇，为什么我没有被什么大公司起诉呢？”我被起诉的原因——我的意思是，理想情况下不是因为我撞毁了一辆保时捷，而是因为我赢了一辆保时捷。而且，是的，有太多神奇的事情了，甚至包括你通过把销量集中起来而让统计数据对你有利，但在全国范围内这真的行得通，这种概率到底有多低？是的，是的。
Yeah, it was lots of good and bad luck in that story, I guess. Random chance. It's a good luck sandwich. Some bad luck in the middle. Right. Yep. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，那个故事里有很多好运和厄运，我想。纯属偶然。这是一个幸运三明治。中间夹着一些倒霉事。没错。是的。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。